this is the square inside the city and
we just captured it says this taliban
fighter
the video was recorded in lashkar-ga the
capital of haman province taliban pushed
into lashkar
on saturday people have reported seeing
taliban fighters in the city centre
and entering people's homes lashkargar's
main hospital called emergency
is full communications have frequently
been cut off
with mobile phone videos offering a rare
insight
into what is happening in the city of
200 000 people
the afghan government has responded by
deploying the most elite of its special
forces
it's also conducting air strikes
alongside u.s
forces this audio was leaked of the
commanding general of the regional army
corps
encouraging his men to keep fighting
all our friends our colleagues should
stay on their checkpoints if any bad
person tries to enter the city we have
commandos there and they will respond
there are airstrikes ongoing by the
americans and by our air force too
don't worry but there is growing concern
about civilian casualties from
airstrikes
now happening in urban areas this
hospital was hit on saturday
the taliban also published these videos
of soldiers it says surrendered in
lashkargar
in recent days
more than 20 times i ask the government
to help us and resupply us
i know they can't help so that's why i
surrendered and came to the taliban
they kept saying on the radio we will
come and help you but it never happened
in the neighboring province of kandahar
fighting is also intense
the taliban has moved inside the limits
of kandahar city
afghanistan's second largest and the
armed groups form a stronghold
we've seen an increase in the number of
injured we have 30 to 40 injured people
here
but the fighting increases during the
night so we might get more patients
later
more than 150 000 people have been
displaced in kandahar in the last three
weeks
most fled from rural areas to kandahar
city but now
even that is not safe when the fighting
started in our village everyone was
fleeing so we also ran from our houses
to here
we didn't bring anything with us just
our clothes we didn't save our things
just our lives these southern cities are
not the only ones under pressure in the
past month the taliban has taken control
of much of rural afghanistan
meaning more provincial capitals are
also effectively under siege
charlotte valas al jazeera kabul